Alright guys, so in this video, I will teach you the ICT silver bullet trading strategy.
On my YouTube, I have already uploaded a video on this topic, but it is not like in detail.
But in this video, I'm going to explain each and everything in detail and how you can trade
it to make profits, if that makes sense.
Okay, so what ICT exactly says, listen to this very carefully.
He says that before 10am, New York time, look for a liquidity that has been swept, okay?
So before 10am, look for liquidity that has been already swept, right?
Before 10am, look for liquidity that has been already swept, okay?
Now once you identify the liquidity that has been swept, you want to identify liquidity,
right?
That has not been swept yet, okay?
So let's say that, okay, one minute, you have buy site here and you have sell site here,
right?
So this is buy site liquidity and this is sell site liquidity, okay?
So let's say before 10am, you see that price has taken out these equal highs over here,
okay?
So now price could be going up, you know, could be consolidating, what not.
But after 10am, right, after 10am, look for market structure shift with displacement
on one minute time frame, okay?
So let's say the clock hits, let me go here, the clock hits 10am right here, so 10am, yeah?
Now you want to start looking for market structure shifts, okay?
So let's say you get a beautiful displacement, okay?
Like that.
Now ICT says you mark out the frame of the gap, you take your entry, you put your stop to
five handles, okay?
Five handles on Emani S&P, it's going to be somewhere around it, I'm going to teach you
what it means, okay?
But for now, he says your stop loss goes to five handles and you take profit goes to
five handles.
So basically, he tells us to aim for one to one.
Now that in my eyes is very low, okay?
But it has, he says that it has a probability of around above 80%, okay?
So you're going to win most of the time.
However, what I've noticed with my back testing is, is when you can simply go for one to
two, that is the perfect risk to reward ratio for the strategy that I've found back
testing, okay?
And when price goes to like one to one, you go break even.
So when price comes back to one to one, you go break even.
So here are some key things that you must note.
So let's say there's like a significant low here or maybe here, you know, a significant
one, okay?
And price takes out that low before coming back to your entry.
Then you have to be cautious, okay?
Because price has already taken out sale site, it could just go back up again.
You want to identify.
So let me give you this little example here.
So this is external market structure, right?
And inside this, you're going to have like this low, low, low, high, low, low, low, low,
low, low, low, low, low, low, okay?
So you want to look for market structure shift of internal market structure, okay?
You do not want to look for this.
If price comes back and takes out this low here and then comes back to your entry, do
not take that.
Okay?
It's not going to work out.
You must identify the internal market structure, which is this, this right here on the one
minute timeframe.
You look for a market structure shift happens right here with displacement, take your entry,
go for five handles and or just put your stop at the high over here and go for one
to two.
So let me, let me show you what I mean by handles, right?
Let me go to futures right here.
Okay.
So let's say that your, for example, okay, let's say your entry is at the close of this
body.
You put your entry here.
Now notice this number right here stops 3.50, right?
It shows 3.50, you move it to five and that is your five handles stop loss.
You go for one to one, that is your five handles, take profit.
So let me give you guys a couple of examples and then we will move on to the next topic.